Greetings to my 3ABN family and welcome
to another 3ABN Today Bible Q&A. I'm
Ricky Carter and I'll be your host.
We've got another another hourpacked
program with your questions. You know
what? We've got the answers here in the
word of God of which our panel will be
sharing with us. So, let me introduce
you to them. To my right, we have
brother Derell Thomas. Welcome, brother.
Thank you. It's good to be on here with
you guys again and to find answers from
God's word. Amen. Amen. I'm looking
forward to that. Next to him, we have my
brother Ian Vandervoke. Welcome,
brother. Hey, Ricky. Thanks for having
me. I'm just ecstatic to be here. It's
always a pleasure to be in Bible Q&A. I
get to learn along with, you know,
answering the questions, so I really
enjoy it. Amen. Amen. And then next to
him via Skype, we have my brother,
Pastor James Rafferty. Welcome, brother.
Thank you, Ricky. It is good to be here.
As soon as I found out that Ian and
Daryl was gonna were going to be on
this, I said, I got to be on this Q&A.
So, I'm thankful for their uh friendship
and for this opportunity to answer
questions. Amen. Amen. Amen. Well,
before we read the word of God, why
don't we start off with a word of
prayer? Pastor James, could you lead us
in prayer, please? Yes. Father in
heaven, just want to thank you for this
opportunity to speak into our audience
to answer their questions. Want to pray
that you'll be with Ricky as he leads
out with Derell, with Ian, myself. Guide
and direct our hearts to heaven. send
your Holy Spirit to be with each of
those that are listening. We ask in
Jesus name. Amen. Amen. Amen. Well,
before I give the first question, let me
remind you at home how you can
participate with 3ABN Today Bible Q&A.
There's one of three ways that you can
do so. You can send us your questions by
email to bible
qa3abn.tv. That's bibleqa3abn.tv.
or you can text us to
618-2283975. That's
618-2283975. And then for those of you
who are on Instagram, you can send us
your questions in that way at 3ABN
official. At 3ABN official. All right,
Pastor James, I got the first question
for you. You ready? Yes. Here we go.
If I go to church on Sunday, will I
still go to heaven as long as I'm
reading my Bible and believing in Jesus?
That question was sent to us by a chat
from our on our website.
Great question. You know, we're not
actually saved or lost by the day we
keep or even by reading the Bible. We
are saved by believing in Jesus. you
know the day we go to church and the
time we spend in the Bible are important
only as they are informed by our
foundational belief in Jesus Christ. So
the Bible teaches this in a number of
places. For example, let's look at 1
Corinthians chapter 3 and we'll start
with verse 11. It says there Paul
speaking for other foundation can no man
lay than that is laid which is Jesus
Christ. So Jesus Christ is the
foundation of all salvation of all
faith. Now, if any man build upon this
foundation, verse 12 says, gold, silver,
precious stone, wood, hay, and stubble,
every man's work, verse 13, shall be
made manifest, for the day shall declare
it, because it shall be revealed by
fire, and fire shall try every man's
work of what sort it is. Verse 14, if
any man's work abide, which he has built
thereon, he shall receive a reward. If
any man, verse 15, if any man's work
shall be burned, he shall suffer loss,
but he himself shall be saved, yet so as
by fire. So Jesus is the foundation. Do
you believe in Jesus as your personal
savior? Period. Then we build upon that
foundation. What do we build? There are
two types of material mentioned. There's
gold and silver and precious stones. And
then there's wood and hay and stubble.
Now the first material refers to the
truth of God's word, the gold, silver
and precious stone which is enduring.
The second material refers to ideas and
traditions of men which will burn up in
the day of God. Sunday observance is an
idea of man. It is an invention of man.
It is a commandment of man. It has no
foundation in the Bible. Sun worship in
the Bible is identified as an
abomination by God. We read that in
Ezekiel chapter 8. And we'll talk about
that in a question we have a little
further on. Yet, there are many people
who go to church on Sunday and they are
true believers in Christ and they have
the foundation. And when the mark of the
beast crisis is fulfilled, when
Revelation 13 comes to pass, these
sincere believers who have a sure
foundation in Jesus will find that they
have built on that foundation wood,
hand, stubble, and it will be burned up.
But they can be saved, but it will be a
fiery trial. So why not build gold and
silver and precious stones now? Why not
step into the truths of God's word right
now? Why wait for the day of trial to
burn up our wood and our hay and our
stubble? Why not worship God according
to his word right now? Hope this answer
has been helpful. Amen. I like that.
Pastor James, thank you so much. All
right, Brother Derell, got your first
question. Sure. The Bible tells us that
Judas betrayed Jesus and sold him to the
chief priests. He had remorse for doing
this but didn't repent. Was there a
possibility for him to repent and be
forgiven after Jesus was given over to
the judges? What was the cut off point
in terms of time for Judas to repent
after Jesus was passed into the hands of
his enemies? And that's from Tadassi in
Minnesota who texted that to us. All
right. Thank you for your question,
Tadassi. And your question actually
brings to light the depths of the love
and mercy of God and the uh the
willingness of God to uh rescue people
from sin uh who repent. It says uh in
the Bible that uh Judas uh went out to
betray Christ uh and we know that he
betrayed him with a kiss. But it wasn't
even at this point that uh the Bible
teaches that Judas's fate was sealed. It
wasn't when he left the upper room to
betray Christ. Uh it wasn't even when he
threw down the 30 pieces of silver that
his fate was sealed. You see, the
forgiveness of God can go even deeper
than that. Judas still had a chance to
repent and to be forgiven all the way up
until the point that he took his own
life. Now, it's true that Judas betrayed
Christ uh and his mind was under new
management. We're told in uh John
chapter 13 26- 27, having dipped the
bread, he gave it to Judas's Scariot,
the son of Simon. Now, after the piece
of bread, it says that Satan entered
Judas. And so, we know that Judas after
that point went out and everything that
he did after that point was being
encouraged and led by Satan himself. But
I repeat again that it was until Judas
took his own life that he lost all hope
of salvation. Notice the hope that is
contained in Luke 8 26-30. It says then
they sailed to the country of of the
gatherines which is opposite Galilee.
And when he stepped out on on the land
that is Jesus there met him a certain
man from the city who had demons for a
long time. When he saw Jesus, he cried
out, fell down before him, and with a
loud voice said, "What have I to do with
you, Jesus, son of the most high God?" I
beg you, do not torment me, for he had
commanded the unclean spirit to come out
of the man. Jesus asked him, saying,
"What is your name?" And he said,
"Leion." Note this, "Because many demons
had entered him." Just as Satan had
entered Judas, many demons had entered
this man. But when he met Jesus, it
says, "Then the demons went out of the
man." In verse 33, then many from that
that area came and found the man from
whom the demons had departed sitting at
the feet of Jesus, clothed and in his
right mind. They also who had seen it
told them, "By what means he who had
been demonpossessed was healed." And so
the fact that many demons had entered
this man meant that uh they had gained
control over his mind. But when that man
met Jesus, the demons lost their control
over that man completely. Amen. Amen.
And so he was sitting there clothed and
in his right mind. He was sitting there
healed. This could have been Judas's
experiences as well. But he took all
hope of salvation away from himself. He
took the power of God to save him away
from God when he took his own life and
took matters into his own hands. Right.
Sad. Well, thank you, brother. Thank you
for sharing that. All right, Brother
Ian, I've got your first question. Yes,
sir.
Why do those I pray for seem to prosper
while my while my own life seems to fall
apart? And that was another message that
came to us via chat on our website. You
know, whoever sent in that question, you
are absolutely not alone in this. Often
times we see our enemies and those who
we pray for seem to prosper where our
life seems as you mentioned to be
sinking. But I want to give you some
hope because we also see this in the
Bible as well. You could read the psalm
of Asaf in Psalm 73 and uh it says
starting in verse three, for I was
envious of the boastful when I saw the
prosperity of the wicked for there are
no pains in their death but their
strength is firm. They are not in
trouble as other men, nor are they
plagued like other men. Their pride
serves as a necklace. Violence covers
them like a garment. Their eyes bulge
with abundance. They have more than
their heart could wish. They scoff and
speak wickedly concerning oppression.
They speak loftily. They set their mouth
against the heavens and their tongue
walks through the earth. So you could
see this in the Psalm of Asaf, how he's
just pouring his heart out, saying, "All
these others that I see who are wicked
and speaking against you and me that
they seem to be prospering." And even in
verse 12, it says, uh, we're going to
read 12-4. It says, "Behold, these are
the ungodly who are always at ease. They
increase in riches. Surely I have
cleansed my heart in vain and washed my
hands in innocence. For all day long, I
have been plagued and chasened every
morning." you know, but then if you
continue reading on in verse uh 17, it
says, "Until I went in the sanctuary,
then I understood their end." So, this
is just yet another reason why the
sanctuary message is important. But, you
know, we also see Job uh experience the
same thing and what in questioning God
whether you know why is he going through
the things that he's experiencing and
the losses that he has. And you know how
God answers? God answers in Job in verse
38:2 and he says,"Who is this who
darkens counsel by words without
knowledge?" God even continues on
saying, "Where were you when I laid the
foundations of the earth? Who determined
its measurements? Who stretched the line
upon it? To what were its foundations
fastened and who laid its cornerstone?"
And when Job came to realize who he was
talking to and who he's actually
questioning, Job's response is in in
chapter 40 of verse 4. And he says,
"Behold, I am vile. What shall I answer
you? I lay my hand over my mouth." So
for the for you who who sent this in, we
may not understand why others seem to be
prospering, why those who seem yet to be
our enemies um in perception maybe in a
worldly fashion are doing better or
prospering more than we are. But if they
do not have a relationship with God,
then we know their end. It's and we can
rest assured that our relationship and
the saving power of Jesus Christ in our
life, we can rest assured on that. And
if you are experiencing some things in
your life, remember James 1 2-4. My
brethren, count it all joy when you fall
into various trials, knowing that the
testing of your faith produces patience,
but let patience have its perfect work
that you may be perfect and complete,
lacking nothing. Amen. Amen. Thank you,
brother. Amen. Thank you. All right,
Pastor James, here's your next
question. Can you show where the
abomination of desolation is the Sunday
law? That's from Robert in Oklahoma who
texted that to us.
Thank you, Robert, for that question.
That's a great question. The abomination
of desecration or desolation, which is
described throughout the Bible. It's
mentioned four times in the book of
Daniel. In Daniel 8:13, in Daniel 9:27,
in Daniel 8:31, and also in Daniel
12:11. And it has three applications in
prophetic history. The first desolation
spoken of by Jesus in Matthew 24, Mark
13, and alluded to in Luke 21 was
fulfilled by the siege of and
destruction of Jerusalem in 70 AD. The
next desolation spoken of by Daniel in
Daniel 8:13, which is connected to the
2300 day prophecy, as well as Daniel
11:31 and 1211, was fulfilled by the
little horn power from 508 AD to
1798/1843 AD. Now this fulfillment of
the abomination of desolation had time
prophecies attached to it denoting the
time of papal supremacy and the time
when this taking away of the daily and
the establishment of the abomination
would continue 508 to 1798 and then 1335
to
1843. The final application is the
Sunday law. And prophecy has outlined
this in Matthew 24 and Mark 13 and Luke
21 has its final fulfillment of this
abomination of desolation in last day
events. So this final application as
well as the first application is not
actually connected to a time prophecy.
This is because Revelation chapter 10
tells us clearly that there's going to
be time no longer. God is no longer
waiting for a time uh element to fulfill
prophecy. He's waiting for the mystery
of God to be finished, which is Christ
in his people, the hope of glory
according to Colossians 1:25 and 26. In
other words, God isn't waiting for a
pope or a Sunday law to happen. All of
those events are in place. God is
waiting for us. He's waiting for a
people who will preach the gospel to all
the world, not just in word, but also in
action as a witness to all nations. then
shall the end come. Now, Ezekiel chapter
8 indicates that when God's people turn
their backs to his sanctuary and they
worship the son, that that is an
abomination to him. Let's just read the
text there in
Ezekiel 8 15 and 16. Then he said unto
me, "Hast thou seen this, oh son of man?
Turn thee yet again, and thou shalt see
greater abominations than these?" Verse
16. And he brought me into the inner
court of the Lord's house. And behold,
at the door of the temple of the Lord,
between the porch and the altar were
about five and 20 men with their backs
toward the temple of the Lord, and their
faces were toward the east. And just to
be clear, Ezekiel says, "And they
worshiped the sun toward the east." So
when we turn our back to God's temple to
God's worship to the seventh day Sabbath
which is laid out in the Bible and we
turn toward the east toward the sun and
worship toward the sun i.e worshiping
the sun we are committing an abomination
that actually makes us desolate
according to Ezekiel 8 15 and 16. So
finally, Revelation 13 and 14 and 18 are
going to point to a time when the entire
earth will engage in the worship of God
in accordance with the authority of
man's traditions and not according to
God's word. And by doing this, they will
turn their backs to God just like
Ezekiel was shown God's professed people
doing anciently. This then will be the
final fulfillment of the abomination of
desolation. And the call will be to come
out of that confusion, out of Babylon
and worship God according to the seventh
day Sabbath laid out in Revelation 14 6
and 7 and of course throughout the
Bible. Hope this is helpful. Thank you,
sir. Thank you very much. All right,
Dell, here's your next question.
If if some angels were cast out with
Satan and some stayed in heaven, were
there some angels cast to earth being
undecided who they wish to follow?
That's from Sherry in Indiana who texted
that to us. Well, thank you for that
question, Sherry. Uh the answer is
actually found in Revelation 12 7 and 9.
It says, "And war broke out in heaven.
Michael and his angels fought with the
dragon. And the dragon and his angels
fought, but they did not prevail, nor
was a place found for them any uh in
heaven any longer. So the great dragon
was cast out, that serpent of old called
the devil and Satan, who deceives the
whole world. He was cast to the earth,
and his angels were cast out with him.
And then when we compare this to verses
3 and four, which says, "And another
sign appeared in heaven. Behold, a great
fiery red dragon having seven heads and
10 horns and seven diadems on his heads.
His tail drew a third of the stars of
heaven, speaking of the fallen angels,
and threw them to the earth. When we
look at this this uh part of the
passage, it it almost seems as though
well maybe they were sent to the earth
by force. Satan forced them to come to
the earth and maybe they were undecided.
But when we combine it with se verses
seven and n it we see clearly that there
was no uncertainty involved in any of
the angels being cast out to the earth
uh they may have uh they made a
conscious willful decision to rebel and
fight against God. And so they chose to
become Satan's angels and hence they
were cast out to the earth and their
fate was sealed. the probationary period
had ended. And in second Peter uh
chapter 2:4 we see that God did not
spare the angels for this reason who
sinned but cast them down to hell and
delivered them into chains of darkness
to be reserved for judgment. And then
Jude 1:6 says, "And the angels who did
not keep their proper domain but left
their own abode, it was their choice. He
has reserved in everlasting chains under
darkness for the judgment of the great
day. And so once the angels were cast
out their judgment was sealed. This is
not to say that when uh that there
wasn't a time in the past that the
angels might have been undecided, but
surely this was before they started a
war against Christ and his angels in
heaven and definitely be before they
were cast out to the earth. Because the
Bible says the words in Revelation 12:7
that when there was war in heaven, it
says that they became uh the dragon's
angels or it says the the dragon and his
angels fought against Christ and his
angels. And so this is a signal that
these angels had picked their side and
there was in no indecisiveness about it
and they were no longer God's angels but
indeed they had become Satan's angels.
And so we see that um each of us has a
probationary period given to us even
angels and the angels had their time to
choose whether or not they would side
with God or whe whether they would side
with Satan but when they came to the
earth their fate was sealed and today we
too have a probationary period. Let's
pray that the Lord will help us to make
us a decision for the Lord. Amen. Amen.
Amen. Thank you brother.
Okay Ian, here's your next question.
Can a divorcee remarry if the spouse
committed
adultery? Romans chapter 7:es 1-3 and 1
Corinthians chapter 7:es
10-13 say if you remarry you commit
adultery please help me understand
that's from FIA in South Africa who
emailed that to us. All right well thank
you Fia. Uh first what I want to do is I
want to kind of cover Romans 7 and 1
Corinthians chapter 7 and bring clarity
to what those verses are speaking about.
So I'm going to read starting in Romans
chapter 7. We're going to do uh 1
through3 and it says or do you not know
brethren for I speak to those who know
the law that the law has dominion over a
man as long as he lives? For the woman
who has a husband is bound by the law to
her husband as long as he lives. But if
the husband dies, she is released from
the law of her husband. So then, if
while her husband lives, she marries
another, she will be called an
adulteress. But if her husband dies, she
is free from that law. So that she is no
adulteress that she though she has
married another man. Now Romans 7:es
1-3, this is actually being used, Paul
is using this in the context of actually
explaining law and grace. uh you can
read in Romans chapter 6:14 where uh
Paul says, "For sin shall not have
dominion over you, for ye are not under
the law, but under grace." So to explain
this in Romans chapter 6, he's actually
already used baptism as an explanation
for it. And he's already used the
relationship between slaves and masters.
And in this case, what he's doing, he's
just drawing uh the same principle about
law and grace from marriage. So, and in
1 Corinthians 7:es 10 through3, I'm
going to go ahead and read that for you
now. And it says, "Now to the married, I
command, yet not I, but the Lord. A wife
is not to depart from her husband. But
even if she does depart, let her remain
unmarried or be reconciled to her
husband. And a husband is not to divorce
his wife. But to the rest, I, not the
Lord, say, if any brother has a wife who
does not believe, and she is willing to
live with him, let him not divorce her.
And a woman who has a husband who does
not believe, if he is willing to live
with her, let her not divorce him. So
these verses in 1 Corinthians chapter 7
verses 10 through13, these are actually
referring uh to a man and a woman who
came together in marriage prior to
having a relationship with God. And at
this point, one of them has now has a
relationship with God and the other one
doesn't want to. They're kind of saying,
you know, I didn't sign up for this this
I don't want to be a Christian. I don't
want to follow God. So really those are
the two contexts between Romans 7 and 1
Corinthians 7. Romans 7 being explaining
and just drawing from uh the principles
of marriage speaking about law and grace
and in here talking what Paul's actually
speaking about is uh two people who came
together not under Christ and then one
of them follows Christ. Now I also want
to remind you that g these are Jesus's
words in Matthew 5 and 32 where it says
but I say to you that whoever divorces
his wife for any reason except for
sexual immorality causes her to commit
adultery and whoever marries a woman who
or excuse me and whoever marries a woman
who is divorced commits adultery. And
again Jesus says in Matthew 19 and verse
9 and I say to you whoever divorces his
wife except for sexual immorality and
marries another commits adultery. and
whoever marries her who is divorced
commits adultery. So in these two verses
we can see that uh under the context or
under the grounds that you have
suggested of on sexual immorality that
you are then free to remarry someone
after that point. But something I also
want to draw out and make clear that the
concept of divorce was never in God's
original plan. Amen. uh in Genesis 2 and
verse 24 it says therefore a man shall
leave his father and mother and be
joined to his wife and they shall become
one flesh. This is what God intended for
the marriage to be where we can come
together in one flesh. And also in the
in Matthew 19 which I read earlier in
verses seven and 8 uh starting in verse
or actually we'll just read verse eight
and it says he said to them Moses
because of the hardness of your heart
permitted you to divorce your wives but
from the beginning it was not so. So
even though there might have been some
type of transgression committed against
you as the spouse there is uh
forgiveness and healing that can take
place even though sexual immorality has
taken place. So, it wasn't in God's
plan. Be in prayer on what and how God
would have you to move forward. Amen.
Amen. Thank you for your answer,
brother. Amen. Amen. All right, Pastor
James, before I give you your next
question, let me remind our viewers at
home how you can participate. One of
three ways. You can send us your
questions via email to
bibleqa3abn.tv. That's
bibleqa3abn.tv. Or you can text us to
618-228-3975.
That's
618-228-3975. Or for those of you who
are on Instagram, you can send us your
questions that way at 3ABN official. At
3ABN official. All right, Pastor James,
here's your third question. In
Revelation chapter 4, John, while in the
spirit, was given a glimpse of the
throne room of God. Who are the four
creatures that John saw? That's from
Jeff in Zambia who emailed that to us.
Great question, Jeff from Zambia. Thank
you for that question. You know,
regarding the four beasts or some
translations of the Bible call them four
living creatures, these living creatures
are actually angels. Now we know that
when we compare
Revelation 4:es 1-9 to Ezekiel 1,
Ezekiel 10 and Isaiah 6:es 1-7 and also
Revelation 7, excuse me, Daniel chapter
7. So the features of the living
creatures, uh, one feature is that
they're like a man, another is that
they're like a lion, another is that
they're like an ox. and then as a flying
eagle. They represent the work of the
angels specifically on planet earth.
Now, there are some Bible texts that
will really help us to to understand um
and support this this symbolism. First
of all, we're told in Hebrews 13 and:e 2
that angels appear on earth as men. So
these four living creatures uh have the
appearance of a man as well as a of an
ox as well as of a of an eagle. The the
appearance of the man reminds us that
angels come to earth many times as men
in the form of humans according to
Hebrews 13:2. And there are many other
verses that we can look at to show that.
Uh but Hebrews 13:2 says, "Be not
forgetful to entertain strangers, for
thereby some have entertained angels
unaware." Mhm. Now, lions, these angels
have the appearance of a lion. That is a
representation of God's authority and
power on earth. We can read about that
in Matthew 28:es 2-4. The angel of the
Lord comes from heaven to roll back the
stone and his raignment is as white as
snow. His countenance is like lightning
and because of him the keeper the
keepers of the of the tomb of Christ
shake and they become as dead men.
That's the authority and power of God.
Now, the ox uh represents the angels
that perform self-sacrificing labor for
humanity. We see that in Hebrews chapter
2 and verse 15. Context. But I say unto
you, to which of the angels said he at
any time, sit thou my right hand until I
make my thine enemies my foottool. Thy
foottool. Are not they all ministering
spirits sent forth to minister for them
that shall be heirs of salvation?
Eagles. Eagles. swift swat fly swiftly
and that would represent the swift work
of these heavenly angels. Daniel 9:21
talks about how when c when Daniel was
speaking in prayer by the time he got to
his the end of his prayer an angel the
angel gabriel had already been sent to
swiftly to touch him about the hour of
the evening oblation and the number four
represents the four directions of the
earth compass that is northsoutheast and
west it suggests that these angels
minister in all directions of the earth
north south east and west they surround
the world because we know that their
number is uh thousands times and
thousands uh in and they are in service
for mankind uh without end. That is
24/7. Thank God for an angel that
watches over each one of us. So these
living four living creatures, these four
living beasts represent the tireless
ministry of God's heavenly angels in
behalf of mankind. Amen. Amen. Thank
you, sir. Thank you very much for that.
All right, brother Derell, here's your
third question. If Adam and Eve had
eaten from the tree of life, could evil
have been
eradicated? What about Lucifer? Did he
have the opportunity to eat from it?
That's from Martin who emailed that to
us. Thank you for your question, Martin.
Uh the simple part uh the simple answer
to the first part of your question is
that if Adam and Eve had have would have
eaten from the tree of life and obtained
immortality, uh the result would have
still been the same. God would have
still destroyed sin and sinners in all
their forms, whether they be angels or
humans, because nothing could hinder God
from his plan to eradicate sin from his
universe as we see in Nahm 1 vers9. Yet
your question does bring to light uh the
beauty of the plan of salvation because
the incarnation of Christ was a vital
element of the plan to save human beings
from destruction and so much was at
stake uh when when mankind had sinned
and when God when when accomplished
God's rescue plan would have given
humanity access to immortality in a
manner that would not be a curse to
them. Without this rescue plan, had Adam
and Eve gained immortality while still
in their sinful condition, they would
have been doomed to eternal and final
destruction in the lake of fire with the
devil and his angels. Adam and Eve would
have inherited a form of im immortality
similar to that which Satan and his
angels have. That is a nature that while
it is not susceptible to mortal death as
humans die, it is subject to eternal
destruction by hellfire. Mhm. For 2
Peter 2:4 says, "God did not spare the
angels who sinned, but cast them down to
hell and delivered them into chains of
darkness to be reserved for judgment."
And Matthew 25:41 tells us that that
judgment is everlasting fire prepare
prepared for the devil and his angels.
In other words, complete and utter
destruction. And so God wanted to
prevent this from happening to humanity
without giving them a chance to repent.
Thus, the plan was put in place for
Christ to die a substitutionary death
for us. Meaning, he would die a death
that would satisi satisfy God's wrath
against our sin. And in order to
accomplish this, Christ had to, and I
emphasize, he had to come with the same
mortal biological makeup that we have in
order for him to become or be or to be
made subject to death. Mhm. He also had
to come into the world in the same
manner in which each and every son and
daughter of Adam comes into the world,
which is found in Galatians 4:4, which
says, "But when the fullness of time had
come, God sent forth his son born of a
woman." So this meant that he would have
to take on the same human flesh that
each of us possess. And when he had the
nature of God, Christ could not be
subject to death in any form according
to Psalm 90:2.
nor could he take on the nature of
angels for that too is conditionally
immortal based on the condition of
absolute obedience and loyalty to God.
So for instance concerning the second
part of your question if Satan had eaten
from the tree of life it would have made
no difference to his nature uh because
uh he was already doomed to be du uh to
be destroyed u and it says in Luke 20 36
uh it speaks of the immortal nature of
angels. It says that when we are uh
redeemed, it says that we will have a
nature similar to the angels and we will
no long we will never die. And there is
uh also uh these things can also be seen
in uh Hebrews chapter 2:9, Hebrews
chapter 4:E1 15 um where Christ uh had
to become one of us in order to benefit
us. So none of this would have been
possible if our first parents ate of the
tree of life. The fruit while it
perpetuates life, it cannot atone for
sin. Adam and Eve would have been stuck
in their sin eternally and Christ could
not have died as their substitute. God
seeing this placed a flaming sword to
guard the way to the tree of life
because of his undying love for
humanity. He would not sit back and let
them perish without giving them another
chance to choose him instead of sin and
Satan. Sin will one day meet its end.
and so will Satan and his angels. But
because of God's infinite wisdom and
love, we don't have to be destroyed. For
God in Romans chapter 8:3, by sending
his own son in the likeness of sinful
flesh on account of sin, he condemned
sin in the flesh. Amen. Thank you very
much for your answer, brother. Thank
you. All right, Ian, here's your third
question.
What is the meaning of John
14:14? I understand that we are to ask
for things consistent with God's will
and that sometimes God's answer God's
answer to prayers is no. But this text
says the answer is yes. That's from
Andrew who emailed that to us. All
right, Andrew. Um, you almost kind of
answered your question, but I'm just
going to help you out a little bit.
Uh, one of the things that we have to be
mindful of anytime we're reading God's
word is to never just take one verse or
one text and apply that that that's what
it means. Amen. Uh, to give you an
example, Philippians 4:13, many people
know this verse. For I can do all things
through Christ who strengthens me. Now,
there could be people or there actually
are many people who apply that to I can
just do anything I set my mind to and
gain any worldly thing that I want
because I can do all things through
Christ who strengthens me. Now, if you
just take that verse, then yeah, that's
sure. That's what it means. However,
when you look at its full context and
what Paul is talking about both before
and after that, Paul's really referring
to how he can just accomplish all things
whether he's in distress, whether he is
full or whether he's empty, whether he
has riches or whether he's poor, that he
can do all things in any scenario that
God places him in. No matter what the
trials or tribulations may be, God is
with him and can pull him through. And
that's really what Philippians 4:13 is
saying. So with that being said, let's
jump to John 14:14, which says, "If you
ask anything in my name, I will do it."
So again, by only reading this verse,
you're going to think that I can just
ask for anything and God's going to give
it to me. Now, let's look at verse 13
right before that. And it says,
"Whatever you ask in my name, that I
will do." Now, here's the key. That the
father may be glorified in the Son. So,
one thing that is important to note is
that anything that you ask must glorify
God. And if you keep reading in John 14,
you'll see that Jesus talks about
keeping his commandments, that he'll
send the Holy Spirit. That Christ will
not leave us orphans. And if jump down
to verse 27, it says, "Peace I leave
with you. My peace I give to you. Not as
the world gives do I give to you. Let
not your heart be troubled, neither let
it be afraid." So what Christ is going
to give you is not necessarily what the
world wants to give you. He's going to
give you exactly what you need and maybe
not be exactly what you're asking for
which you even alluded to by saying
sometimes the answer is no. Now also in
1 John chapter 5 14-15
uh it says now this is the confidence
that we have in him that if we ask
anything according to his will he hears
us and if we know that he hears us
whatever we ask we know that we have the
petitions that we have asked of him. So,
what I want to leave you with is just to
again to be mindful that because you
pretty much answered your question that
sometimes God answer is no. And that
anytime you're reading God's word, don't
just take one verse or one text and
apply it. Uh I'm going to actually kind
of give a little plug here. This is
something that we teach in our 3BN
school of disciplehip in one of our
basic classes, which is how to study the
Bible. So, make sure that you check that
out if you're interested. And this is a
great opportunity for just to make sure
that you read both before and after. Get
the full context of everything that
you're reading so you can have a clear
understanding of God's word. Amen. Amen.
That's right. Amen. Scripture says,
"Line upon line, precept upon here a
little, there little." Amen. All right.
Thank you, sir, for that answer. Pastor
James, here's your final
question. I've heard it said that the
New Jerusalem is about the size of the
state of Oregon. If that's the case, not
very many people are going to be saved.
Does this include those who will inherit
the earth? That's from Carolyn in
Kentucky who texted that to us. Thank
you, Carolyn in Kentucky. Yes, I do
believe that all who inherit the earth
will have a place in the New Jerusalem
city. Jesus says of his followers in
John 14:1-3, "Let not your heart be
troubled. You believe in God, believe
also in me. In my father's house are
many mansions. If it were not so, I
would have told you, I've gone to
prepare a place for you. If I go to
prepare a place for you, I will come
again and receive you unto myself, that
where I am, there you may be also. So,
this would include the Old Testament
faithful as the new Jerusalem is
described as having 12 gates and the 12
gates, 12 angels, and the names written
thereon, which are the names of the 12
tribes of the children of Israel. It
would include the New Testament faithful
because it says in verse 14 of
Revelation 21, "And the wall of the city
had 12 foundations and in them the names
of the 12 apostles of the lamb." So the
new Jerusalem city has a large
mansion-like place for all of the
redeemed. And now what a thrill it's
going to be to be there with the
redeemed. As for the size of the city,
can you even imagine a city the size of
a state? Mhm. Oregon is almost
100,000 square miles. Tokyo, one of the
largest populated cities in the world,
is
240, a measily 240 square miles and it
has
37 million people. Now, if I'm doing my
math correctly, that means that
approximately 416 Tokyo cities can be
into the space of the state of Oregon or
the New Jerusalem. That would allow for
bill392 million people. And of course,
this is based on the idea that the new
Jerusalem would be limited to the
dimensions of our earthly cities. Yet,
we're also told the new Jerusalem is as
tall as it is wide. Amen. Verse 16 says,
"The city lies four square. The length
is as large as the breadth. He measured
the city with a reed, 12,000 furongs.
The length, the breadth, and the height
of it are equal." Mhm. So now we have
unlimited room for what the Bible
describes as a great multitude that no
man can number. And of course God being
the architect who knows what fabulous
innovations he's going to give us that
we're going to discover someday. The
Bible says that as it is written eye has
not seen near the uh has the ear heard.
1 Corinthians chapter 2:9 neither has
entered into the heart of man the things
which God has prepared for them that
love him. But we just described the new
Jerusalem. So we must have some idea.
Yes. Verse 10 of 1 Corinthians 2 says,
"But God has revealed them unto us by
his spirit. For the spirit searches all
things, the deep things of God." So, we
do have some idea of what the new
Jerusalem city will be like. It's as big
as a state. It's larger than 400 Tokyo.
It's able to accommodate over 15 billion
people, not including the upward
heights. And our sure reality about the
future is it's going to be beyond
anything we can imagine on planet Earth
today. So let's make God's heart happy
and determined to be there. You know,
Revelation 22:17 says, "The spirit and
the bride say, "Come." And let him that
hearth say, "Come." And let him that is
a thirst come. And whosoever will, let
him come and take of the water of life
freely. What do you say to the Holy
Spirit? Will you come? Amen. Amen. I
pound being there. How about you? Amen.
Let's all be there, right? Let's meet
there. All right, Brother Derell, here's
your final question. I know the Bible
says to get out of the cities. It seems
that cities have been built up
everywhere. What do I do as a senior
citizen with disabilities? That's from
Dot in Maryland who texted that to us.
Thanks, Doc, for your question. That
question uh is close to my heart because
I have a son who has a disability. So I
know how much of a trying ordeal it can
be to make such a decision. Um and
you're correct that the Bible does teach
that because of the worsening uh
corruption and vice that we see in the
cities especially the larger ones
throughout the world uh that there is a
great importance of uh leaving the
cities for more more rural um areas and
this can be seen in the comparison
between the living living arrangements
of Abraham and Lot. uh we have Lot and
his family living in a corrupt city and
they by contra and then by contrast we
have Abraham and his family living in a
simp the simple life um of the country
land in in the Canaan land. The Bible
says that God delivered righteous Lot in
second Peter 2:es 7 and 8. It says God
delivered righteous Lot who was
oppressed by the filthy conduct of the
wicked. For that righteous man dwelling
among them tormented his righteous soul
from day to day by seeing and hearing
their lawless deeds. And when Lot left
the city of Sodom, he had he he left
with pretty much nothing. Uh and so he
had to leave everything behind. And so
he had ample time to leave Sodom before
that, but he waited far too long to
leave. And likewise, it is a truth that
one day it will become extremely hard
for us to leave the cities uh if we do
not leave now. And so God uh says when
when God says to go, we should move
quickly. But at the same time, we see in
Abraham's story that Abraham's move to
country life in Canaan was all about
timing and location, location, location.
You see, God specifically told Abraham
not only when to leave his homeland, but
also where to go in Genesis 12:es 1-7.
And Abraham received the call to go at,
and you'll like this, he received the
call at 75 years old. So, age is no
hindrance, amen, to to country living,
but timing can be. You see, when Abraham
left his home in Haran, Genesis 12:5
tells us that he left with a number of
people and a number of supplies needed
for country life. It says, uh, in verse
5, it says in Genesis 12, "Then Abram
took Sarah, his wife, and Lot, his
brother's son, and all their possessions
that they had gathered, and the people
whom they had acquired in Haran, and
they departed to go to the land of
Canaan." So, here's a key takeaway. In
addition to knowing when to leave the
cities and where to go, which is a
decision that must be made between
individuals and families and God,
there's also the necessity of properly
preparing before we go. So for the
disabled, this means do you have access
to proper medical care? For the elderly
and disabled, I would personally advise
uh not to move alone because country
living is not simply about u barely
surviving, but it's truly about
thriving. Um and and remember that Jesus
said we must be wise as serpents and
harmless dove as as doves uh according
to Matthew 10:16. So don't make rash
decisions. And if you feel like God is
impressing you to move to the country,
don't delay, but pray and seek wisdom on
how to both prepare and obey the call to
go. And remember, God says, "And my God
shall supply all your need according to
his riches and glory by Christ Jesus."
says Philippians 4:19. Amen. Great
answer. Thank you, sir. Thank you. All
right, Ian got your last question.
Can you please explain 1 Timothy chapter
2 14 and 15? That's from Jackie in
Georgia who emailed that to us. All
right, Jackie in Georgia, great state.
Used to live there a little while while
stationed in the army. So, let's go
ahead Jackie and uh let's read 1 Timothy
2 14-15. And it says, "And Adam was not
deceived, but the woman being deceived
fell into transgression. Nevertheless,
she will be saved in childbearing if
they can if they continue in faith,
love, and holiness with self-control."
Now, much of these verses is actually
referring back to Genesis 3. So, I'm
going to go ahead and read that with
you. Genesis chapter 3, we're going to
read verses 1 through3, which says, "Now
the serpent was more cunning than any
beast of the field which the Lord God
had made. And he said to the woman, "Has
God indeed said, 'You shall not eat of
every tree of the garden?'" And the
woman said to the serpent, "We may eat
the fruit of the trees of the garden,
but the fruit of the tree which is in
the midst of the garden, God has said,
"You shall not eat it, nor shall shall
you touch it, lest you die." Then this
dialogue continues to take place with
Eve and Satan or the serpent. And uh it
goes on by saying, "For God knows that
in the day you eat of it, your eyes will
be open." This is Satan speaking. and
you will be like God, knowing good and
evil." Now Eve started to entertain what
Satan was was saying to her, and she saw
the tree that it was good for food, that
it was pleasant to the eyes, desirable
to make one wise, she took of its fruit,
and she ate and did exactly what God had
commanded her not to do. And rather than
obeying those commands, even if just for
a moment she had disobeyed God and
entertained the suggestions of the
devil. Now the supporting verses that uh
that Eve was the one that was deceived.
In verse 13 of Genesis chapter 3 says,
"And the Lord God said to the woman,
what is this you have done?" The woman
said, "The serpent deceived me and I
ate." In 2 Corinthians 11:3 says, "But I
fear less somehow as the serpent
deceived Eve by his craftiness, so your
minds may be corrupted from the
simplicity that is in Christ." So here
it just laying out the the examples or
how it was that Eve was the one who was
actually deceived and transgressed God's
laws. Now going into Adam, we know that
he actually sinned as
well. And uh now let's look in verse 15
though of what you were questioning in
first Tim 1 Timothy chapter 2. We're
going to look at verse 15 here which
says, "Nevertheless, she will be saved
in childbearing." You can read this in
Genesis 3 and:e 16. To the woman he
said, I will greatly multiply your
sorrow and your conception. In pain, you
shall bring forth children. Your desire
shall be for your husband and he shall
rule over you. And again, I mentioned
just earlier that Adam also fell into
sin. We can read about that in Genesis 3
and verse uh 17. And basically what
happened there is that instead of
listening to the commands of God, Eve
just or he listened to the words of Eve
and took of that fruit and ate. But I
want to focus on real quickly on verse
15 where it says if they continue in
faith, love, and holiness and with
self-control that they will be saved. So
if they, so speaking about Adam and Eve,
right? Hebrews 11 verse 6 uh verse 6
says, "But without faith it's impossible
to please God." 1 Corinthians 13:13. And
now above all faith, hope, love, the
greatest of these is love. And then 1
Thessalonians
5:23, now may the God of peace himself
sanctify you completely. So here we're
saying those same things in verse 15 of
of 1 Timothy if they continue in faith,
love, and holiness. So here we have it
outlined, and I hope that gives you a
clear understanding of uh what we went
over in First Timothy. Amen. Amen. Thank
you for that answer. Amen. I know that
was a lot to cover. So, Oh, no. It's
good. It's good. Oh, I know. I was
blessed. How about you? I'm sure you
were blessed by the answers that we got
from the word of God. And you know,
there are some other places where you
can find some of these answers on our
website. Have you heard of this website
3ABN Bible
answers.com? Have you heard of that
site? That site's a wonderful site. Go
there. You can get your answers to
questions like top on the topics of the
mark of the beast. Questions like what
is the mark of the beast? Is it a
monster computer system? Uh is it hidden
somewhere in Europe? Uh or is it a
microscopic chip to be embedded under
our skin? There's also questions that
you can find in there on the gifts of
the of the Holy Spirit. Um questions on
the prophecies of Daniel. qu questions
on the latter reign. What is the latter
reign? How do Christians receive the
Holy Spirit? So check out that website,
3ABN Bible answers.com. You'll be
blessed. Now, we're going to take a
short break so to remind you how you can
participate with 3ABN Today Bible Q&A.
So don't go away. We'll be right back.
We want to get some final thoughts from
our panelists. We'll be right back.
If you're enjoying our 3ABN Bible Q&A,
then tell your friends. Each Monday,
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's Holy Word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand. To have your questions
answered on a future program, just email
them to us at
bibleqa3abn.tv. That's bibleqa3abn.tv.
You may also text your questions to
618-2283975. That's
618-228-3975. Be sure to include your
name and where you live and then watch
through Bible Q&A for answers from God's
word. Well, our time is almost up. Let's
get some final thoughts from our
panelists. Brother Drell, I just want to
uh touch on the subject of Judas and uh
the probationary period that existed for
him. Now, while uh I had mentioned that
Judas when he left the upper room, there
was still he still had breath in his
body, he still could have chosen uh to
turn back to Christ. But when he left
that upper room, he had already his
decision had already been sealed. He
already had decided to resist the light,
the great light that was given to him.
Uh this is in comparison to the demoniac
who had not received all of the great
light that Judas had received. And so
similarly to uh Lucifer once he made his
decision to rebel against the Lord uh he
had received even greater light than
than Judas himself. But in both cases
they had sealed their fate long before.
And so this is why we see that even with
the angels, judgment was prepared for
them uh many many years ago, thousands
of years ago. And so I just want to
convey that uh we don't want to risk
missing out on salvation because while
we may still have breath in our bodies,
we can't say at the last moment that we
will turn around and make a decision for
Christ if we're not making a decision
for him today. Amen. Amen. Amen. Brother
Ian, yeah. I just want to kind of
reiterate a lot of the questions that at
least that I was answering today really
comes down to the foundation of how to
study the Bible. So if this is something
that you're interested in on, you know,
you could be reading God's word for a
long time. You could be, we've had
people come to our 3BN school of
disciplehip just wanting to know how do
I study my Bible? So if you want to know
more and you want to join the school of
disciplehip, you can go to
3abnsod.com and you can just check out
what we have there and I know it'll be a
real blessing for you. Amen. Pastor
James. Amen. I just wanted to second
what Derell said. It was very well said.
And then also second what Ian said and
pass it on to you, Ricky. Amen. Amen.
Hey, it's been great worshiping with all
of you and studying God's word.
Remember, we are living in the last
days. The Lord is coming soon. Hey,
let's meet under the tree of life.
Thanks for joining us. God
bless. Heat. Heat.
[Music]